a
arriver? Reportage de Mathieu
Papillon et entrevue avec la
médecin.
- Ça, c'était au début, là.
Dans les débuts, quand je suis
allé à l'hôpital, là.
J'étais magané.
- Réal Vézina va se souvenir
longtemps de son mois de janvier
2022, marqué par un mal intense
et mystérieux.
RÉAL VÉZINA
- Plus ça allait,
plus j'avais mal à la tête.
Au niveau de... du front,
ça commençait, tu sais, à me
démanger. Et oups, ça a été
l'oeil, après ça. Puis là, quan,
il me l'a dit tout de suite.
Il dit : "Vous faites du zona."
- Près de 27 000 Québécois
contractent la maladie
chaque année. 600 d'entre eux
doivent être hospitalisés
et 10 en décèdent.
Dre CHANTAL SAUVAGEAU,
médecin spécialiste, INSPQ
- Le zona, dans le fond,
c'est la réactivation du virus
de la varicelle, qu' f f fait
généralement plus jeune,
qui est resté latent en nous,
puis qui se réveille,
des années plus tard.- Parmi le:
des sensations de brûlure
d'un seul côté du corps,
des démangeaisons
et l'apparition
de rougeurs localisées.
- Si on réussit à être chanceux,
puis avoir une forme dite
légère, puis que ça partrararar.
Si on le détecte assez vite,
on peut avoir aussi
des traitements qui vont
raccourcir la durée.
- Réal Vézina n'aura pas eu
cette chance. La maladie l'a
cloué au lit p u u u un mois.
- Ah, tu ne fais plus
grand-chose, tu sais.
Tu dors, tu essaies de dormir,
tu récs.s.s.s. Les maux
de tête sont encore là.
- Et comme pour près du tiers
des personnes atteintes,
aiaiaiains de ces symptômes
se font encore sentir,
des mois plus tard.
- Regarde, la plaque d
je te parle, c'est celle-là.
Elle est ici, là.
- Vous la sentez encore,
celle-là.
- Oui, oui, je la sens encore.
Sur l'oeil, de temps en temps,
il va me passer des chocs
électriques. Tu sais, je suis
guéri, mais... pas tout guéri.
- C'est pour éviter
des histoires comme celle-là
qu'il y a cinq ans, le Comité
sur l'immunisation du Québec
a recommandé que le vaccin
contre le zona soit offert
gratuitement aux plus de 50 ans.
- À 50 ans, on voit vraiment
une incidence qui augmente.
Puis, autour de 70 ans,
on voit une autre augmentation,
un autre plateau qu'on atteint.
C'est jugé coût-efficace
de vacciner contre le zona
pour prévenir les consultations,
les hospitalisations,
les décès associés au zona.
Et ça ne compte même pas
dans l'équation les douleurs et
les souffrances des individus.
ÉRIC GIRARD,
ministre des Finances, Québec
- Le gouvernement consacre
près de deux milliards
de dollars aux aînes.
- lelelelelelement
dans son dernier budget
que Québec s'est engagé à donner
le vaccin à 800 000 personnes,
sans préciser le groupe d'âges
qui sera ciblé.
Il faut actuellement payer
plus de 300 $ pour obtenir
les deux doses requises.
- On est très contents de ça.
- La mesure réjouit
les représentants des aînés,
qui la réclamaient aussi
depuis des années.
GISÈLE TASSÉ-GOODMAN,
présidente, Réseau FADOQ
- Il y a bien des personnes
qui ne peuvent pas se permettre
de payer ce 300, 300 quelques
dollars pour obtenirle vaccin c.
- J'ai ma petite pension,
ça fait que je vis avec ça.
Ça fait qu'oublie ça, je ne
suis pas capable de me payer
un vaccin, moi, là, de 300 $.
J'attends mes chèques
à la fin du mois.
- On saura dans les procha
semaines quel groupe d'âges
aura droit au vaccin gratuit.
La suggestion de M.
- 65 ans! Pas 70 ans!
- C'est ça, vous prêchez
pour votre paroisse, là.- Bien !
- Ici Mathieu Papillon,
Radio-Canada, Ste-Marguerite-
du-Lac-Masso